what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and with spider-man no
way home coming back to theaters on
september 2nd with new footage and
scenes that we've never seen before a
lot of people have been asking me what's
the news on spider-man right now what is
the news with sony spider-man universe
and also spider-man 4 and of course
probably the biggest question what is
going on with the amazing spider-man 3
and andrew garfield because we haven't
really heard anything for quite some
time now and with the new extended cut
of spider-man far from home coming out i
thought this would be the perfect
opportunity to talk about that and
everything we know about sony spider-man
universe the amazing spider-man 3 and
spider-man 4. and of course we can't
forget about venom so let's dive into
this video and what you need to know
about the upcoming spider-man in the mcu
and the sony spider-man universe also in
case you didn't know like i mentioned
the new spider-man no way home release
comes out september 2nd it will have 11
minutes of new footage including new
footage of the three peter parkers
together not as spider-man but as peter
parker's being the science bros so that
is definitely going to be worth the
watch right there now what is going on
with the other two spider-man andrew
garfield and toby maguire now as of
right now we've actually gotten an
official statement from marvel studios
president kevin feige and sony executive
producer amy pascale stating that they
are indeed going to be working on a
spider-man 4 and in fact they already
are working on spider-man 4 with tom
holland but as far as the other two
spider-man go we haven't really heard
anything at least officially but if you
followed the channel all throughout the
spider-man no way home journey you know
that there were a lot of leaks out there
a lot of them ended up on my channel and
a lot of them ended up being true and
these come from the insiders the
scoopers the leakers and the news about
toby maguire and andrew garfield is
coming from those same leakers and this
news pretty much states that sony does
indeed have plans for andrew garfield
and toby maguire now sony does have more
plans for andrew garfield than toby
mcguire of course because of their age i
think toby maguire was fantastic in
spider-man knowing home it was amazing
to see my favorite spider-man on screen
again but he is a little bit older now
that doesn't mean that he can't appear
in some movies and heck i'd still give
him his own movie but it seems as of
right now sony wants him to appear in
other projects in their sony spider-man
universe possibly keeping their
multiverse going with madame webb which
we'll talk about in just a bit but of
course the question that everybody has
been asking me about is what exactly is
happening with the amazing spider-man 3
is there a possibility that it could get
made with angie garfield and the answer
is quite simply yes according to things
that we've heard recently and insiders
sony does indeed want andrew garfield
back they want him to play a decent part
at least in their spider-man universe
sony needs a spider-man in their
universe and sony in marvel studios made
it pretty clear that that spider-man
wasn't really going to be tom holland
now they teased us that it was going to
be tom holland in that post-credits
scene for venom let there be carnage
where eddie brock and venom make their
way to the mcu but sadly we know that
that was just kind of to hype up no way
home even more than it was already hyped
up because quickly not too long after
that we saw the post-credits scene for
spider-man no way home where we saw
eddie brock and venom again but they
left the mcu back to the sony universe
but they left a piece of the symbiote
behind telling us that tom holland is
going to go up against a different venom
symbiote that is not tom hardy's eddie
brock that was insanely sad and a very
very big tease but it actually opens the
door for andrew garfield to kind of be
the main spider-man of the sony universe
now according to several insiders like
daniel rpk my time to shine hello yes
sony has plans for andrew garfield and
recently there have been reports that
andrew garfield has actually signed a
multi-movie deal not only with sony but
with marvel studios as well most likely
returning as the amazing spider-man but
also making an appearance in avengers
secret wars now when we heard that
andrew garfield had signed a multi-movie
contract one of those being in the mcu
secret wars had not been revealed yet we
knew that it was going to be coming but
we thought it was going to be coming
many many years later than 2025 i was
actually quite shocked when they
revealed secret wars is coming in only
three years but if we backtrack a little
bit that makes sense that andrew
garfield would have already signed a
multi-movie deal with secret wars being
one of those movies because secret wars
is only three years away it looks like
marvel studios is really starting to
plan if this report is true and again
based off of what some insiders have
been saying how sony wants andrew
garfield to stick around in the universe
and toby maguire as well it really seems
like a lot of things are adding up and
just to reiterate and make clear what
we've heard is that sony does want
andrew garfield to stick around and play
spider-man for multiple projects and we
have heard that the amazing spider-man 3
could be one of those projects insiders
have also stated that sony does want the
three spider-man to reunite again at
some point in time in the future they
would like to do another multiverse film
with the three spider-man and i think a
lot of us would really really enjoy that
i know i would now it sure does look
like sony is planning on introducing
their own multiverse their own
spider-verse in the sony universe
obviously we have the multiverse within
the mcu but sony wants to do that within
their own universe with all of their
characters like craven the hunter venom
and it all comes down to madame webb
madame webb is filming right now and if
you don't know anything about madame
webb there's one really important thing
that you need to know about her well two
one is that she is essentially a cosmic
entity in marvel comics and two she can
travel the multiverse she has the
ability to travel through universes and
apparently madame webb is supposed to be
a really big movie for sony's spider-man
universe and that makes sense
considering the fact that she can travel
through other universes this is actually
a perfect setup for andrew garfield
spider-man and toby maguire spider-man
to stick around even if they don't get
their own movies they can still go to
their respective universes and we can
get them back on screen from what we've
heard it seems like this kind of fits
into their plan of tobey maguire
returning and cameoing in movies but not
getting his own while on the other hand
it's been said that andrew garfield is
going to play more of a prominent role
in sony spider-man universe possibly
getting his own movie and possibly going
up against tom hardy's venom in venom 3.
tom hardy confirmed that venom three is
indeed going to be him going up against
spider-man before venom let there be
carnage came out he said that that was
ultimately the end goal for the next
film and he's already teased us after
venom let there be carnage has come out
teasing us that he is still indeed going
up against spider-man and that just
makes sense and the post-credit scene
for venom let there be carnage he said
maybe i should go find the spider-man
guy now he's back in his own universe
but he should probably still go find
spider-man that's probably what he's
thinking because he did just travel
through another universe he's probably
going to have some questions so the
amazing spider-man 3 is definitely on
the table for andrew garfield to return
and make but at this point in time i am
expecting to see andrew and toby
probably in a few projects on the sony
spider-man universe and then hopefully
they both show up for avengers secret
wars now as far as spider-man 4 in the
mcu with tom holland is concerned like i
mentioned kevin feige and amy pascal did
say that they are already working on
spider-man 4. no we have not heard
anything from tom holland but i think
that tom holland has learned that he
can't spoil stuff anymore but both
studios have pretty much already stated
that yes he's coming back zendaya and
jacob battle on as well plus let's not
forget that they did indeed tease venom
in the mcu in the post-credits scene for
knowing home granted it's a different
venom than tom hardy's but he was teased
nonetheless they might have not signed a
new contract yet which is why we haven't
heard much but since sony and marvel
studios both said they have plans for a
spider-man 4 i'm assuming he'll
definitely be coming back and let's not
forget this exciting piece of
information avengers secret wars is
actually where spider-man runs into the
venom symbiote for the very first time
in the comics it's the first time that
we see spider-man wear the black
symbiote suit so who knows maybe in
spider-man 4 spider-man gets the venom
symbiote but doesn't give it away and
maybe he'll go on to have that suit
still in secret wars so that is pretty
much all the information we know so far
about all three spider-man and the two
different spider-man universes the mcu
and the sony spider-verse of course if i
hear anything else i'll be sure to let
you all know and do a video on it so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest spider-man news
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
you